In a previous video, we described a
number of different options that are
available inside of the Windows control
panel. But Microsoft has slowly been
migrating a number of those settings to
a new front end known as the Windows
settings app. This settings app is one
single place that you can go with a
single consistent user interface. And
there are a number of different
parameters that you can configure to
customize your specific Windows setup.
To find the Windows settings, we simply
go down to the search option inside of
Windows and we look for settings. And
you can see that the settings app is the
option that is the best match in the
system. This is the settings app. You
can see along the left side are a number
of different categories. And the main
part of the screen shows details for
each of those categories. Let's step
through a number of these categories and
see what options might be available to
change within our Windows configuration.
Under the time and language category,
you'll see options for date and time,
language and region, and more. Under the
date and time settings, you can
configure Windows to set the date and
the time automatically, adjust for
daylight saving time, set the time zone
and the region you happen to belong in,
and more configuration settings. This is
a very important setting, especially on
a corporate network, because some of the
encryption required by Microsoft's
Active Directory requires that the time
be correct on your computer. So, if you
wanted to have Windows set this time
automatically, you would change the
option under set time automatically to
on. Windows also has the ability to set
different languages as part of the
operating system. And under language and
region, you can specify which language
you would like to use for your Windows
operating system.
There's also an option for Windows
update within the Windows settings where
we can choose to keep our operating
system up to date with all of the latest
patches and latest updates to the
operating system. You can set Windows to
install these updates automatically so
you don't even have to think about them.
Your system will constantly keep itself
up to date with all of the latest
updates available from Microsoft. You
can also select active hours so that
these updates don't occur during your
normal workday if you'd like. Windows to
avoid making any of these updates when
you're normally working. You can
configure those within your active
hours. If you're using Windows at home,
you might even have options to change
the personalization of your operating
system. This allows you to change the
colors in your operating system, the
background that's shown, and information
that's displayed as part of your lock
screen. In a corporate environment, some
of these features may not be enabled on
your Windows system, but if you're using
Windows at home, you can customize
Windows to look and feel exactly the way
you'd
like. The Windows settings also allow us
a way to configure what applications
might be installed in our system. That
is done in the apps category. You can
uninstall, install, or modify an
existing application from this list. You
can also add other Windows features. So,
if you'd like to install other services
or include other fonts to be included as
part of your operating system, you can
enable or disable those under the
Windows
features. The privacy and security
category is one screen that allows you
access to a number of different security
features. For example, inside of privacy
and security, you can enable anti virus,
firewall settings, and change how
network protection is being used on your
Windows device. We can also specify how
much information we would like to share
from this Windows operating system. For
example, you might want to choose to
share your application activity so that
you get customized advertising on the
Windows desktop. You also have the
ability to share what language you might
be using so that other websites know
what type of content to present to you.
And you can also determine whether
speech recognition is something you'd
like to enable or disable. Often the
speech recognition requires a
third-party site to send this audio so
that it can be processed. And from a
privacy perspective, you might not want
to send that information to a third
party. To be able to manage all of the
different pieces of hardware connected
to your Windows computer, you can use
the Bluetooth and devices category. From
inside of this category, you can manage
audio settings, information about
Bluetooth configurations, and manage
other devices such as printers that you
might be using. You can also manage
mouse settings from inside of this
category. So, if you want to change what
the buttons are doing on your mouse, you
can do it within Bluetooth and devices.
We also have options for your typing and
writing. So, if you're using keyboard
functions, they can be customized inside
of this view. And this is also where you
can customize your Windows pen or
Windows ink. If you're using a tablet or
a device that takes advantage of a
stylus, if you need to make changes to
the network configuration, you'll find
it in the Windows settings under the
category for network and internet.
Inside of this category, you have
options for your Ethernet connectivity.
You have VPN configurations, any proxy
settings, and if you're still using
dialup, all of your dialup
configurations can be found in this
category. From here, you can easily see
if your internet connection is up and
running. For example, on this particular
system, my Ethernet is connected to the
rest of the world. You can also change
any IP settings. So, if you'd like to
manage your IP configurations, change
the DNS servers that you're using, that
can all be done from inside of this
category. Microsoft has been working
inside of the Windows settings to
integrate their PC gaming world with
their console gaming world. So, you'll
find under the gaming category options
for an Xbox game bar and you can view
and save any of your capture settings
inside of this
category. And the settings also gives us
a useful front end to be able to modify
information about our user accounts. We
can manage both our Microsoft account
and our local user accounts in this
single view. This also allows us to
configure email information. We can
specify what email app we would like to
use and we can modify sign-in options.
So, if you'd like to use some type of
personal identification number or
additional multiffactor authentication,
you can configure that inside of the
account settings.